Lord hesitine thank you for joining us
on Piers Morgan uncensored we really
appreciate it so we've only just
actually left the trading relationship
uh just over two years ago it's the
beginning of a a long-term new
relationship and yet already it seems
that some people are trying to sort of
bring us back ever closer together
um I know that was always your view Were
you invited to this conference
no
would you like to speak so so you feel
you missed out
um but um in terms of where we don't
feel I missed out at all
okay well in terms of where we are since
we left uh the trading relationship
we've got our trade with the EU is
actually up some 10 uh since the end of
the transition period it's up some 40
since the end of 2016. our foreign
direct Investments since uh 2016 uh is
about the highest of any uh European
nation uh well comparable so it seems to
me that people are sort of
um
they're essentially sort of talking down
bricks it's before actually it's been
given a chance to maximize the
opportunity
well if the figures that you've just
given were accurate why are people so
upset why is there a concern I mean
you've just depicted a Triumph let me
let me just sort of help you a little
you see it's not the people like me did
you see today's Telegraph
brexit is dead
yes I did that was it obviously your
most fanatical supporters so that's why
how can your greatest supporters allow
this sort of adverse propaganda which we
published that was so that was that was
the evidence
that was an article by yeah
but the point is what she was concerned
is that the establishment figures let's
start again what about this one the bank
of England
people a thousand pounds worse off the
Daily Telegraph it's not me it's your
friends
the reality is that our GDP growth so
the reality I've just told you what the
reality is I've just told you what the
reality is no the reality is the figures
you've been doing for six years how can
you dare to say that it's only two years
or four years the referendum was because
nearly seven years ago and the people
who were in charge in the government of
the day Boris Johnson Liam Fox David
Davis did you think they knew what they
were doing two years before we had a
general election then we were told we'd
get brexit done why now are we still
waiting to know what that means I'll
tell you why because it meant a pack of
Lies well Lord hasselton let me tell you
why the reason that we're in the
position we are is because those
remainers such as yourself worked very
very hard to thwart brexit ever
happening so you can recite the many
years since 2016.
perfectly well
you've had six years with your hands on
the levers of power we'd love to have
had six years people like me or simple
Sons
okay Lord has the time bear with us a
second who's doing let's let's come to
our panel uh Anne many people say that
we've got rhino brexit in name only
what's your view of that where do you
think we are in terms of the journey and
the opportunity well I certainly think
we're not taking advantage of the
opportunities that are available to us
uh that is the first thing secondly
those opportunities are limited by the
agreement that was reached which was I
think brexit in name only but even so we
have got some freedoms that we could use
and we're not using them and that is why
people are so disappointed also of
course things have been conflated you
know we've got inflation largely as a
result of huge spending during covid
it's not just confined to Britain it's
in other countries as well but everybody
says Ah you know post-brexit therefore
on account of brexit and that is a
nonsense argument and I you know I I
mean with all due respect Lord
hesselfine you'll know I'm a huge
admirer of Lord hasseltine but he's just
got this one completely wrong we have
not had six years we've only been
legally out for two I think that's a
very valid point
um and withdicam but do you think we
brexities and of course I was also a
very vocal supporter of brexit would we
do well to acknowledge that thus far it
hasn't been a Triumph we have to kind of
accept that bit it isn't that brexit
hasn't been a Triumph it's that how we
have handled brexit hasn't been a
Triumph that deal which we all warned
was flawed right from the start uh is at
the root of a great many of the problems
that we have brexit isn't to blame what
we are doing or rather what we are not
doing with brexit is to blame I can see
Paula
if you're going to do a job yes let's do
it properly yes and let's give it a fair
time yes in order to to show itself
absolutely now
but you can't do that if the foundation
upon which you are working is false okay
and that premise was made on a lie it
was built on a lie we lied to those of
us in the East End we lied to those of
us up north we lied to the fishermen
sovereignundated by
um Turkish immigrants who wanted to come
and settle here was that true I think
and the truth is we've had the highest
immigration in the year to June 22 ever
because you didn't regain control of the
borders in the way that we could have
promised
I would like to ask him whether he
thinks that uh the voters were sold a
pack of Lies is that yes what are you
going to say to that absolutely
you think absolutely that was the case
can I can I can I just can I just answer
the question please they were sold a
pack of Lies yes and the greatest
evidence of that is that six years later
when the brexiteers have been in charge
we have not seen any of the benefits
that we were told we would get and
that's because they were all fiction so
I think your six years is fictional you
can't justify that six years
forgive me I I let us be pedantic on
this one matter did the referendum take
place in 2016. yes but we didn't is that
six years uh Lord Hazel time
so look can we can we just just
agree will you please enter the
relationship will you please allow me to
answer the questions you've put to me in
2016 a government was formed in which
Boris Johnson David Davis and Liam Fox
the principal Advocates of brexit were
put in charge of the three most
important departments so they were there
six and a half years ago and Lord has
the time we left two years ago I'm going
to ask one final question to you Lord
House of time before we let you go yes
would you rejoice
would you get on with doing the job
properly
I would get a job done properly by
rejoining the European Union so then
Lord has the time you're gonna you're
gonna negotiate the worst possible deal
with no leverage how ridiculous I
thought you were a successful
businessman
I am a successful businessman well then
you know that that will be a terrible
negotiation disaster
yeah I love your interruptions you see
you won't let me answer the questions
because you can't bear the truth until
you shut me down let me tell you frankly
you you know you never listen that's
your whole problem you've just interrupt
so that anyone who talks something you
don't like you try to shout them down
and I mean we we dealt with the issue a
few minutes ago what was the motive of
Boris Johnson's electoral Victory get
brexit done so why hasn't it happened
because
the promises you see there you are there
you are there you are interrupting again
it's a conversation
this is not this is this is a shouting
match in which your Technique is to
shout down anyone you disagree with you
perfect
I knew when I came on this program I
would have to be behave in a way that I
deplore and to fight get a word in
edgeways because you think that if you
can censor what people are saying by
shutting them down you'll win the Lord
has the time never win the argument that
way we're very grateful for your time
but the truth is you've actually spoken
more than anybody else thank you very
much
for your thoughts and by the way just to
clarify it's only two years since the
end
I'm trying to get the last word I know
the tricks came out too we remember
Paula Paul before we conclude this piece
Lord haseltine would rejoin tomorrow
would you rejoin tomorrow and can I
answer that in as long as time as you
can give me George Eustis told us how
things have gone wrong he finally
admitted how things had gone wrong and I
have my friends and family in the East
End who can tell you how it's gone wrong
we have the fisherman who can tell you
how it's gone wrong we have those up
north we can have those who are uh
get it done properly
it's voted get it done properly